- Do you need me to clap?
- [Man] Yes, please.
(claps)
Alright.
(lively music)
- We're gonna have to make a pancake today
in 10 minutes all the way from scratch.
- Three people from the
Office are gonna judge
our pancakes, the winner will be crowned.
- So the winner gets a 50
dollar gift card to IHOP.
- I consider myself to be
the ultimate pancake queen
because I make really fluffy,
thick pancakes at home.
- I grew up making pancakes every Saturday
and Sunday morning.
- Having to make pancakes
in 10 minutes is a challenge
because I take a long
time making my pancakes,
I separate the wet ingredients
and the dry ingredients.
I don't know how it's gonna turn out.
- I'm not even gonna
lie, it seems impossible.
But if I have a strategy
before I get to everything,
I should be able to rack it out.
- I don't even know how
much I'm gonna put in here.
And I also don't have a measuring spoon,
so I'm trying to guesstimate.
- Dry ingredients are
the most important part.
Gotta move faster!
- I'm gonna crack an
egg, start whisking that.
- My milk, oh wait, just kidding I need
my baking soda first.
- I'm gonna go for the milk.
And I'm just gonna put in
a little bit at a time.
♪ I want some of your brown sugar ♪
- No singing Bianca, concentrate.
- Still pretty thick,
there's still some lumps.
This is a rather bullshit pancake.
- Alright, I gotta make
sure these are not lumpy
because if it's lumpy
when it hits the skillet,
I'm sorry, it's a wrap.
Oh, my vanilla, guys,
could you imagine if I had
forgotten my vanilla?
That would have been an epic fail.
- Starting to get pretty battery.
This looks ready to go.
- I don't know, I feel
like I need more something.
- I'm going to use some butter.
- This timeframe has got me going.
- My first pancake always is trash.
I'm hoping it turns out
kind of decent though
because I don't have the
time to mess up my first
pancake like I usually do at home.
- Oh no, that's not looking good.
I feel like I need more flour!
Damn it, damn it.
- While this is happening,
I'm gonna cut up some bacon.
- There we go!
Come on pancake, gimme something.
Yes, now that looks about right.
- I'm watching this pancake
to try and figure out
when it bubbles, when it starts to bubble
I'm going to flip it
because then I know it's
basically cooked up on one side.
- Are we gonna cancel that first pancake?
That pancake does not count.
I'm gonna drop some blueberries.
- This is starting to look kind of fubbly.
I'm gonna just...
Flip.
It looks kinda gross, but it's okay.
Hopefully it tastes alright.
- I don't know, I feel
like I failed this quiz.
It's okay.
Even when you feel like you fail,
you just keep going.
- Now this is always the hard part,
because it's the first pancake.
I could never tell when it's
fully cooked on the bottom,
so I just kind of touch
it and take a look,
yeah, it looks good, one done.
- My presentation's gonna be whack.
Look at that, that's awful, I'm ashamed.
I'm still in it to win it.
These pancakes are probably
gonna taste terrible.
- I don't know how much time I have left.
Shit.
I'm gonna turn up the heat
a bit and I'm gonna panic
a little bit and I'm gonna
drop some bacon in here.
- Look at this pancake, I'm
just gonna leave that there.
I'm just gonna keep going.
- This pancake looks like
it's doing its thing,
I think I might be able to pull this off.
- These actually don't look too bad.
Ooh, these look good, okay, here we go!
- I am making this Elvis
style, so I am putting
peanut butter on this.
Drop these bananas on, more bacon bits.
- Sorry, okay.
(tense music)
That's it.
- I have some time.
So I'm gonna add a little
more brown sugar to this.
I don't have much time.
- I don't know!
Oh yes, we need syrup, these are pancakes!
Ah!
I hate my life right now!
- And now we have some
syrup and that's that.
I'm done!
(dramatic music)
Hopefully they're the
best 10 minute pancakes
anyone's ever had, that's
all we can hope for here.
I don't know, I haven't tried them myself.
- First of all, it's like doused.
- I'm loving that.
- It's basically
peanut butter.
- Syrup.
- With a side of pancake.
Is this bacon on the top?
- [Man] You have to get banana it here.
- Oh shit, that's good.
- That's actually good!
- I know.
- I like the bacon and the
peanut butter, actually.
- The peanut butter is
surprisingly not that overpowering.
- The fluffiness is...
- On point, on point.
It looks scary to eat.
- It did.
- It tests better
than it looks.
- I thought this was a
pancake thing, these look...
- Sad.
- Crepes?
- Yeah, crepes, dead crepes.
- I'm excited about the four strawberries.
- I love them, it's pretty.
- They add color.
- Let's go for it.
These actually look really freaking good
now that they're on my fork.
- It's actually good.
- this is good.
- I like the blueberries.
- I like the fruit theme
they have going on.
- I'm definitely gonna have
to go with the second one.
- It's the second one for me.
- I have to go with the second.
- It felt less filling,
this one's lighter.
- Yeah, the other one was super hearty,
but this one is perfect for
a nice little Sunday brunch.
- What?
- Pancake queen!
Honestly, I was like, these
pancakes are the worst.
- I tasted yours off the
grill and it was so delicious.
Mine were getting dry and they were doused
in peanut butter and maple syrup.
- I feel like peanut butter,
who doesn't love peanut butter
and maple syrup?
- There's a lot of peanut butter.
Usually when I like, cook
anything, I take my time
with it.
- Same.
- I set up my measurements.
- Having the time crunch
was playing with my head
a little bit.
But I had a blast.
- It was fun.
- Yeah.
- It was really fun.
- [Bianca] You just kind
of go with it and let loose
and even when you feel
like you're failing,
you have to keep going because
you have to present something.
- You won for taste, man!
That's huge!
(triumphant music)